following the release of her first
single head above water Avril Lavigne is
back with single number two her upcoming
album this is tell me it's over just
came out moments ago what do you think
[Music]
[Music]
it sounds like something in the Kip
maybe someone will figure out cuz the
lily came out yeah we'll use go yeah if
you could figure that out that because
it's gonna start driving me nuts - I
like Avril listen I heard last song head
above water was it mean it's not it's
not a commercial it's not a commercial
track I don't think it was designed to
be so but I think that it was a great
sort of rebirth for her after everything
that that poor woman's through and I'd
like this song it's fine it's you know
it's not a virile it's not but we always
complain that everybody does the same
thing over and over again and then when
they do something that is completely
different where they do appear that
they've grown I think that you have to
embrace that you know and it's a brand
new it's a brand new after all I like it
and so far I mean I've always been a
moderate fan of Anna love you know is
found a music Pleasant but all these
first two songs I loved head above water
yeah love this song through like very
bluesy and ever thought if you're at
Lavigne doing a good bluesy doesn't like
it a dowel feel a little bit as well
yeah this is loving it Arlene says like
it yeah why does this sounds like a song
from the 50s at house that kind of like
shoo [ __ ] Motown II kind of feel to move
Adele there's some song it does sound
like Zachary says it sounds a little bit
like Beyonce superpower feel to it no
it's an older song that the melody is an
older Matthew sister voice makes me feel
so much tune feelings yeah for voice
sounds almost better than River I mean
this isn't mr. upbeat tunes maybe
they'll still be some skater boy songs
in the album that's only two songs
there's like whatever another ten songs
never know
you